vous savez en plus nous accueillons
notre invité du samedi 20 heures ce soir
william rejault
dans son livre maman est ce que ta
chambre te plaît sur vivre en maison de
retraite aux éditions privé toujours en
compagnie de jean dujardin
et devient rémission
alors il ya un mois jour bonsoir vous
êtes ici parce que vous avez été
infirmier en maison de retraite
rassurez-vous pierre il n'est pas là
pour
non ne partez pas
il n'a pas beaucoup bu là pendant
pendant l'émission il ya un risque de
déshydratation
alors williams vous avez écrit un livre
bouleversant sur les maltraitances dont
sont victimes les personnes âgées dans
les maisons de retraite et votre livret
remis au coeur de l'actu avec la sphère
de l'établissement les colombes à
bayonne et quand on lit ça on comprend
pourquoi drucker veut pas décrocher
c'est sûr pour les chabot
fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui j'aimerais je re bonsoir ont
publié aux éditions privé maman est ce
que ta chambre te plaît sur vivre en
maison de retraite qui est un
bouleversant témoignage sur les
conditions de vie des pensionnaires de
ces établissements voilà d'abord votre
expérience donc après quelques stages
vous êtes embauché dans une première
maison de retraite qui s'appelle la
sirène en alsace alors dès le début
évidemment le le pire vous est réservé
les odeurs la saleté
les traces de merde sur les mur dit vous
les dentiers qui traînent dans les lits
la nourriture des jours précédents qui
reste là sans que personne ne l'enlève
quoi je veux dire le pipi caca je passe
ma journée dedans non ce qui me gênait
c'est effectivement les traces de merde
sur les murs échec personnes avaient
nettoyé et ce qui gênait c'était de voir
des vieux à l'abandon livrés à eux mêmes
moi j'étais j'étais assez choqué mais ça
ne choquait que moi ou en tout cas si ça
choque et d'autres personnes on en
parlait peu ouais
vous n'êtes pas eu envie d'arrêter à ce
moment là non j'ai pas eu envie
d'arrêter je pense que c'était important
contraire de continuer de me dire écoute
il faut que tu vois ça et qu'un jour tu
puisse témoigner à l'époque j'étais
j'étais intérimaire parfois est bon je
me disais tu vas rester là deux semaines
trois semaines puis tire à voir ailleurs
et puis j'arrive dans une autre mission
d'intérim dans une autre maison de
retraite et je retrouvais les mêmes
conditions ouais je me disais bon si tu
joue de malchance en fait et woods le
dixième maison de retraite on joue de
malchance vouziers qu'un petit problème
dans ce pays peut-être
alors voilà ensuite vous devez
travailler à paris dans une résidence
qui dans top 5 des maisons de retraite
pour le nouvel observateur c'est la
meilleure oui mais quand on voit comment
les journalistes font leur enquête ils
arrivent comme dans les prisons on voit
tout et tout et briquet tout est parfait
dans dallas vient exactement voilà quand
ça coûte quand même si 1500 euros par
mois
et la direction mais god surtout - oui
ce qui me gêne le plus c'est que les
gens qui paient autant et je me dis
quand on paye 6500 euros n'a droit quand
même un service de qualité mais
n'accepte pas ça alors là déjà le
personnel vous parle aides africaines
non diplômés mal payée peut considérer
donc rien que ça déjà c'est à des gens
qui sont en contact avec les malades
avec les vieillards en tous les cas sont
même pas la hauteur de leur tâche quoi
c'est son étage qui sont tellement
ingrate
allez quand même nettoyé les personnes
âgées tous les jours c'est un beau look
est très dur des personnes âgées
démentes donc on trouve du personnel qui
est pas qualifié on soupèse et c'est les
filles qui n'ont pas trop le choix soit
ils se font ça soit le fond caissière et
encore comme souvent certaines sont
africaines est ce qu'elles ont trouvé du
boulot en tant que caissière là on les
prend on les balance avec les personnels
timer des personnes démentes et puis et
puis les maires de toi alors voila mais
malgré tout vous prenez d'amitié pour un
couple c'est très touchant dans votre
bouquin ils ont 96 ans il s'appelle
monsieur et madame guénantin et alors ce
qui est terrible c'est que leur économie
leur permettent de vivre dans cette
maison de retraite encore un an et demi
voilà ça veut dire qu'après ils savent
même plus où ils vont aller ça ils vont
aller dans la rue quoi
c'est dur
je suis avec des gens qui me disent on
n'a pas beaucoup d'économies le peu
qu'on a nous permet de durer donc on a
envie de vivre parce qu'on a quand même
envie d'être tous les deux ils sont pas
séparés 1 c'est rare mais un couple
d'amoureux à 16 ans alors et en même
temps on espère qu'on n'a pas mis trop
longtemps parce quand on aura plus tout
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire de nous ils
vont nous mettre à la rue premier de ces
nous qu'on partira pas à la rue bon
c'est ça c'est dur c'est très dur alors
voilà il ya des trucs terribles ya là il
ya la fille qui refuse de tenir la main
de quelqu'un qui est en train de mourir
je jette pas la pierre j'ai tenu la main
d'une dame qui est morte je me rappelle
encore son nom je me rappelle encore de
la chambre c'est des choses qui m'ont
vraiment marqué je suis heureux de
l'avoir fait mais je me souviens encore
et je pense pas que je puisse le faire
20 x 30 x indéfiniment c'est pas
possible donc je ne jette pas la pierre
sur mes collègues alors voilà donc
évidemment il ya les aides soignants qui
pose les plateaux repas un peu trop loin
pourquoi parce qu'il faut des cif ou
distribué 25 plateaux repas en dix
minutes on compose le plateau obtenu bon
appétit on s'en va qui vient me voir a
le job et là rien manger ip requête
qu'ils ont une semaine voilà où de la
nourriture qu'à un mach abl ça c'est un
grand classique on a une grande boîte on
à la sodexo qui nous fait de la
nourriture les grands repas mexicain
avec des notes choses elles ou avec des
nems ouais on a un chapeau mexicain sur
la tête des vieux on prend des photos
qu'est-ce qu'on est heureux la maison de
retraite et puis les vieilles tantes
entier sont des nems il arrive même pas
le manger la nourriture est pas adapté
mais voilà on a on a fait une animation
voilà ce n'est que ce soit fait
l'animation alors évidemment ce qui est
plus terrible dans votre bouquin c'est
la maltraitance par exemple les vieux
c'est très long de les amener aux
toilettes donc on a armé des couches et
on change pas les couches donc
évidemment ils sont là dedans toute la
journée en fait sur moi quand je lis
livre toujours ça me file à une haine il
donc pour beaucoup de soignants ça
arrange les que les vieux soit un
continent ça nous arrange pas bien
continuer à enlever une couche en soit
cette question alors qu'un vieux
continent c'est quelqu'un qui va sonner
qu'il va falloir mener de dix fois par
jour toi et au bout d'un moment on va
s'énerver on va lui proposer une couche
moi quand j'étais jeune souffre vraiment
jeunes soignants je me dis [ __ ] mais
c'est pas possible on va mettre des
couches aux gens quand ils sont
continent c'est inimaginable et ensuite
en tant que soignant quand on m'appelle
40 fois par jour je vais en vient à
penser que oui la couche est une
solution il ya des exemples que vous
donné par exemple c'est qu'on attache
les malades au pied du lit
comme un chien en laisse c'est vrai ça
non alors la loi la tâche et les malades
mais sur prescription médicale jamais au
pied du lit comme un chien on peut
attacher quelqu'un il ya des déments qui
peuvent se maltraite eux mêmes ceux
frappés eux mêmes donc on a le droit de
les attacher avec une ordonnance par
contre oui je parle d'une dame qui
m'explique m'a raconté ce cas dans le 77
ont attaché les patients comme des
chiens mais c'est assez fréquent moi je
les ai vus dans des endroits où on
attache les patients au fauteuil pour
pas qu'ils se lèvent parce que si cela
ils vont déranger le soignant alors bon
alors il ya des douches glacées
évidemment alors évidemment au bout d'un
moment ils meurent ils attrapent des
rumeurs qu'elles sont glacés c'est que
la fille a diminué pour faire une
toilette elle n'a pas le temps
d'attendre nos chaudes donc là au plus
pressé et elle fait une douche à l'eau
froide on n'attend pas l'eau chaude bon
alors évidemment pas question de parler
de soutien psychologique
j'entendais une dame qui dit j'ai envie
de mourir et l'infirmier enfin l'aide
soignante lui répond mais non mais non
vous n'avez pas envie de mourir
évidemment la fille qu'on comprend elle
est ma forme et la gagne 1 smic elle est
là la des bosses 12 heures par jour on
comprend tout là mais [ __ ] merde alors
le pire mois je trouve le la cerise sur
le gâteau c'est la dame qui dit moi
j'étais plus heureuse à auschwitz comme
l'entente parce qu'à auschwitz ont pensé
qu'on allait s'en sortir ça cogite on
pensait qu'on allait battre les
allemands et qu'ils allaient ouvrir les
camps et comme allait s'en sortir là je
n'ai pas d'espoir de m'en sortir quoi
c'est inimaginable
et alors vous raconter en plus cette
espèce de de mécanisation
du service médical c'est un collègue qui
vous expliquent qu en clinique ils ont
une grille de minutage du temps
relationnel c'est à dire qu'on leur dit
au départ une patiente qui a perdu sa
mère ses 16 minutes
une patiente qui a perdu un enfant ces
27 minutes tout est rationnalisée
vraiment tout ça est rationnalisée parce
qu'en fait les groupes qui possèdent les
maisons de retraite sont cotées en
bourse donc ils veulent faire du
bénéfice est à dire que les gens qui
sont dans ces maisons de retraite sont
victimes comme les ouvriers français qui
se suicident de cette société
financiariste donc quand je pense que
j'entends france télécom 25 suicides et
quand je vois ce que j'ai vu en maison
de retraite c'est strictement le même
problème pourquoi on maltraite des vieux
on maltraite pas parce qu'on est sadique
on est violent c'est une minorité a bien
sûr maltraite des vieux parce qu'on est
pressurisé par un système qui va faire
25 toilettes en trois heures chez france
télécom ils n'ont pas de vieux mal
traités lors suicides nouba qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est bon maltraite dévions
les bouscule on va vite voilà combat là
se passe bien aussi cette idée williams
de considérer les vieux comme des objets
parce que finalement c'est moins
impliquant mais on déshumanise si vous
avez quelqu'un avec un nom un prénom je
vais pas vous maltraitez alors si vous
êtes madame machin de la chambre sont
deux ça va plus vite ça commence
toujours comme ça on tutoie on appelle
mamie et puis on déshumanise et ça
permet d'aller plus vite dans les années
30 ont appelé les juifs des rares comme
comme ça quand ils ont les a raflé ont
raflé pas des êtres humains ont raflé
des rats ou c'est exactement pareil sauf
quand on commence toujours pas chosifié
la personne qu'on veut face c'était bon
alors maltraitance aussi de la part des
familles évidemment pour des questions
d'héritage et nakivale accélérer la mort
jaffray qui veulent la ralentir parce
que ça les arrange et vous raconter un
truc terrible c'est qu'il ya des gens
qui proposent des aides soignants de les
payer pour euthanasier
leur mère ou leur père parce que
finalement ça les arrange quoi je n'ai
entendu moi j'ai un monsieur qui m'a dit
on avait prévu avec maintenant de finir
sa vie en suisse d'une association et
leur euthanasie on peut plus y aller
maintenant on est trop fatigué combien
vous voulez pour pour tuer maintenant je
peux pas faire ça non mais combien alesi
je sais combien vous gagnez vous donne 6
x 10 x ça je dis mais je peux pas
monsieur c'est pas une question d'argent
c'est une question de courage d'abord je
n'oserais jamais le faire ensuite toutes
les conséquences que ça va avoir
judiciairement mêmes même s'emparer du
10 jan comment je vais supporter d'avoir
tué quelqu'un une fois dans la et donc
je vois cette dame qui a besoin de
mourir qui veut mourir et qui le dit
tous les jours je veux mourir et je ne
peux rien faire légalement je ne peux
pas le faire alors on est là qu est ce
qu on fait rien qu'est-ce qu'on fait
rien
alors le pire c'est la peur dire que des
gens qui sont victimes de maltraitance
danser dans ces cliniques dix ans dans
ces maisons de retraite
alors dit écoutez si vous vous plaignez
ça va être pire demain donc ces pauvres
vieux con rien il se passe défendre ou
qui ferment leur gueule la famille ferme
sa gueule pour la condition la condition
des enfants un traité ce qu'on appelait
enfants de l'assistance havrais s'est
amélioré beaucoup pourquoi est ce
qu'avec les vieux on arrive pas c'est la
pompe à fric aussi c'est un orgue rit on
va on n'a plus d'argent quand on cote en
maison de retraite en bourse comme qu'en
investissant dans le pétrole les vieux
c'est une sorte de pétrole qui ne va
jamais s'arrêter de courir il ya
tellement de fric à se faire faudrait
presque du sur mesure à chaque fois pour
chaque personne et c'est impossible on
le sait bien moi ma grand mère qui était
à les amener au dernier degré je veux
dire si elle ne se nourrit plus aller
dans une maison de retraite
dans les arènes et bah oui c'est le mage
mac est là maintenant pour le coup est
ce que tu as le sentiment quand tu vas
l'avoir qu'elle est victime de mauvais
traitements
non je pense pas à ça non on me dit
allez tomber la dernière fois
effectivement elle avait un oeil au
beurre noir les pompiers arrivent aussi
donc un moment on va pas penser à
accuser etc mais c'est effectivement les
chiottes sont dégueulasses effectivement
mais bon
je leur jette pas la pierre je sais pas
du tout comment ça fonctionne maintenant
la ministre c'est une question de fric
c'est une question de moyens voilà au
lieu de faire du profit il faudrait le
mettre dans les soignants il faut
débloquer mais ça coûte des milliards
mélinda dépenses quand même 6 ou 7
milliards par an pour les vieux quand
même non c'est pas suffisant il faut des
moyens humains et si on faisait à vos
enfants ce qu'on fait à vos vieux
beaucoup de crèches qui fermerait mais
deux suites tuerait le parisien qui
serait là tous les médias serait là mais
les vieux on les voit pas les vieux
n'existe pas les vieux nous font peur de
toute façon ne veut pas dire qu'à nous
emmerdent vieillit on veut passer les
autres les vieux regarder les reportages
qu'on voit la télé à chaque fois on voit
dit vieux aligné en train d'écouter de
la musique on veut pas voir ça quand ça
se fait qu'on apprenne maintenant ça
c'est pas qu'on la prend maintenant
c'est que ça fait longtemps qu'on en
parle mais les médias ne veulent pas en
parler ça fait fuir et c'est un problème
de santé que bach on sait pas on
semblait y en a pas parlé jusqu'à
maintenant et quand on en parlait les
gens regarder ailleurs parce qu'on se
disait ce sont les vieux c'est jamais
nous c'est quand même le conte c'est
jamais nous le conte c'est toujours
l'autre va le vieux c'est toujours la
csn plus tard édité et quand vous aviez
bien tant le vieux il avait 30 ans 40
ans maintenant vous avez votre âge et le
vieux il a quel âge il attribue ce que
vous sait jamais vous le rsa sera jamais
vous le vieux
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux